like the like the taiko drum guy or or
you know the eyeball ramen or well yeah
I Ivan Ivan ramen or like people that
even if they fetishize Asian [ __ ] if
they did the work and they studied it
for 40 years and they loved it to death
there is that freedom too I think so
dude I know like who the [ __ ] cares let
him do it Ivan Orkin that [ __ ]
he married a Japanese woman opened up a
popular Japanese restaurant in Japan and
he speaks Japanese yeah it's [ __ ]
Japanese kids what the [ __ ] do you want
from him dude yeah like what else do you
want from this guy now I don't care if
because it's it takes people like that
to bridge the culture together yeah you
know and it's also funny too because I
remember watching his stuff on an unmet
flix and then in the docu-series like
his final statement he goes he goes a
lot of people are telling me that you
know I hear some stuff over there they
might say like this is an authentic
ramen he goes well why don't you open up
a [ __ ] restaurant in Japan
hey good then you come talk to me yeah
gangster it's true though like well how
are you an authority about a food that
you've never made creative apprenticed
under or anything but I've done the work
and I'm creating this dish out of
respect and then now you're telling me
just because you're Asian that you know
what a better a bowl of ramen is because
of the color of your skin yeah fish that
doesn't make sense to me yeah you know I
see this dude he did the work he did the
apprenticeship ASIS to think that
someone that isn't of that culture can
make it good oh yeah got a percent even
when that whole thing happened right the
I who did the whole funny people were so
mad and you know I got a little bit of
flack cuz I defended the guy because if
let's say that would do wasn't white
right yeah it was a Vietnamese guys
everybody would been like yeah that's
how you really eat Vietnamese food
that's how you supposed to do a son but
but all they saw was the color of his
skin and they go he can't say that [ __ ]
I'm like but it's not like he was off
like even when I eat a bowl of pho I
don't put like a bunch of [ __ ] hoisin
and sriracha in the showers I taste that
[ __ ] for ya I taste the broth first
that's all I was told to do it anyways
so it's like oh I relate to guys I [ __ ]
with this guy like what's up I think I
think what people don't want is
people don't know anything about
Vietnamese people hmm already right so
they don't want the white guy to speak
for them yeah because there's plenty of
Vietnamese Americans I get that but they
people also have to understand that it
takes these brave white people to first
care about it to talk to their other
white people yeah and then the more
people get into it they'll get into the
true [ __ ] yeah like that's what happens
sushi oh yeah everybody in the 80s was
like ooh
sushi raw fish gross yeah now it's like
the most [ __ ] expensive thing now
it's like high society food you know all
the richest and famous white people want
to [ __ ] eat it but it wasn't always
like that right but it's like you got to
understand the evolution of how things
get to where they are you can't you
can't you can't be like no no no no like
we you know it has to be us all the time
this is also this kind of like this
level of [ __ ] snobbery with food
sometimes too you know like you know cuz
you know we eat at a lot of like dope
restaurants specifically specifically
because we live in LA yeah but that
doesn't mean I'm not gonna have a
McDonald's soft-serve you know I know
right people talk about food that
they've eaten their whole lives like
it's trash now because now they're
elevated in their food like yo chill
like calm the [ __ ] down
like I'll make like an edge Lord
underground [ __ ] yeah like I'm
like I'll cook like add oatmeal right
but then I guarantee you when you guys
eat the food that I mean I'm eating a
bowl of kimchi yeah so I you know
there's their snobbery - that shit's
like you like what you like man yeah
like I love a good fast-food taco
sometimes yeah like it's like do you
only eat at [ __ ] fancy restaurants
because if you do then you don't really
know food do perception is so [ __ ]
skewed because you know when we went to
Vegas I we ate at that Gordon Ramsay
burger joint and that [ __ ] was not
[ __ ] good it's even in the Yelp
reviews right but all they saw in that
video was me making fun of this burger
and I'm a it's a comedians channel too
by the way and I didn't like the burger
Oh what the [ __ ] do you know about food
did you [ __ ] eat the burger [ __ ] did
you [ __ ] eat the burger like if you
didn't eat the burger then you don't
have a say in this [ __ ] I'm just telling
you what I feel about it
you know what I mean I don't believe in
Michelin star ratings anymore I ate at
three restaurants with over two-star one
was an actual three-star Michelin rating
all of them suck dick oh you I went to
one in France no I went to two in France
it was the second one wasn't so bad
I went to joelrose Shan in Vegas it
wasn't good
no I I paid almost $300 I swear to you I
try to stay optimistic because of how
much I paid I was like the bread is
awesome the water is delicious
I got my main entree which was salty
salted beef cheeks at the end of all
this [ __ ] I was like just lying to
myself because of how much I paid so
you're right I was close to $300
so I'm saying perception is true yeah
what the way the a call comes out but
when I look back the more I started to
hate what I what I was like thinking
because I'm like no it didn't taste good
why did I why did I say that is cuz I
paid a lot of money man people like I
don't know if people could even wrap
their head around this and I think and
what I mean by people I'm talking about
people who are food snobs I feel like
these foods knots can't even wrap their
head around this like I say like have
you had a sturgeon caviar before I think
oh [ __ ] amazing
I'm like really out of all the things
that you've eaten this this this this
fish now I've had sturgeon caviar right
yeah it's good it's a salty fish ball
yeah and you're like um one of the best
things I've ever eaten really bro yeah
if you never saw that on Gordon Ramsay
talking about it or some high chef and
you just saw this this plate of black
balls and you ate that [ __ ]
you would you eat that and be like wow
this is [ __ ] crazy I bet you it's one
of those things like not though you
gotta be a quiet it's got it you got to
build it right I understand what it's
good like I think it tastes good but I
guarantee you objectively speaking this
salty ball of salt water that you're
eating has not is not the best thing
you've ever eaten even truffle the
concept of truffle right it's because
it's an expensive thing you see it on
every [ __ ] cooking show right yeah
but people anything with truffle and
they're like that truffle oil though
what what about it it's just rough yeah
it's good but is it the most amazing
that
you know oh yeah without I don't like I
mean to me truffles meant to be subtle
yeah it's not meant to be like in like
so much you know some people like a lot
of truffle like not me
like it's just it's just some weird and
it's okay like if you have truffle too
and you say I don't like it it's okay
nothing's wrong with your taste buds
yeah just don't like you don't [ __ ] with
it that's all that it is that's very
true yeah like when I say like oh you
don't like this you're tress it's a joke
like I don't actually think that ours is
trash but people take it too seriously
now like oh my god you don't you don't
like [ __ ] a sushi you don't like raw
fish you're [ __ ] your palates not
elevated or they just don't like ya or
they just don't like it
yeah is what it is and a lot of people
can't break down why something is good
yeah because I feel like the better you
are as an artist you can break down the
reasons for why you like this sensation
cuz it's all a sensation right it's like
oh I like the texture yeah oh I like
this kind of taste like I like crunchy
textures or whatever it is right
and a lot of food snobs have you noticed
they don't cook yeah they don't [ __ ]
cook dude they just go around eating
[ __ ] talking but they don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about to me
they remind me of those uh fake art
snobs that walk around yeah art museums
and talk about the artists motivation
and this and that
and I'm just like but you [ __ ]
don't even paint either yo if there's a
food son the thing I want to do too is
like we got to start that [ __ ] food
at like a ha ha let's do it do you know
where my god I want to start this
[ __ ] food app it's like Yelp well you
could rate these restaurants or
businesses but there's open
communication for the users to talk [ __ ]
to each other - yes and they get to up
and down vote whatever the [ __ ] they say
I think it's good there has to be that
type of communication because it's not
fair that the restaurant just sits there
and gets beat down yeah it's it's really
not yeah it's not fair people should be
able to be able to open communicate
because even like the YouTube comments
or [ __ ] cancer but I wouldn't take it
away because you learn a lot actually
yeah yeah you do there there needs to be
that open type of communication - and I
feel like - if you're and I
have this I want to put this thing like
if if you're using the app and you have
over a thousand reviews on it
you're just labeled as a loser the
[ __ ] loser tag that's what you get
dude that's we've got to do it man I
really do want that man I want to do it
I'd [ __ ] promote the [ __ ] out of it
because I want I want I want to get
recommend to a place because it tastes
good yeah that's all I [ __ ] care
about there should be a separate
separate we're thinking about like
having a separate review rating too so
it's not like this cumulative like three
or four star score it's like it's her
thing ambience for low or place food
serving like service service like do
they talk to you whatever cuz I don't
give a [ __ ] about food service yeah so
as long as they're not mean yeah so it's
about like you being able to judge a
place for the rating that you care about
the most
yeah so I was like I care about this
place because the [ __ ] food is
amazing the service is trash but I don't
really give a [ __ ] I just want to eat
that food yeah and a lot of these
restaurants do have that quality where
surface is not on point like
specifically mom-and-pop stores a lot of
Chinese restaurants yeah because it's
just service is different in their
culture yeah which to me I got used to
because I grew up in a Chinese
neighborhood yeah so it's just different
and people write on reviews too they go
oh I would give it like a 3.8 at 3.5
maybe but I gave it a 3 instead of this
well why don't we do it separately where
it's you give them a 5 for the food you
give them a 3 for the service yeah and
the whatever the the one for the
cleanliness because it's a Chinese
restaurant decide whether they want to
go to it or not yeah I think anyone's oh
yeah I love Chinese food man it's so
good see I think I think they cut to the
chase they're like does it taste good
yes let's do it
move on yeah does it look good [ __ ] no
but it takes know you want some but
ankle soup yeah I know that cow head the
eyeballs looking at you but that's good
luck Oh